hello and welcome to this video playing
Conte from Turkey began another system
guys there are more interesting openings
around why do you play that but that all
of the time I completely understand that
you would play it once in a while that's
really ok I mean I've I've played the
London in a tournament game last year
and and actually got an interesting
position with white it's not bad it's
sort of a bad opening and by any means
Oh way he's playing in his sharp fashion
yet no not not doing something boring
here long castles
ok let's see maybe 96 provoke him d5 is
94 ok that's a very simple oh it
actually works
isn't that good
should work
the odds the odds trap can be quite
effective okay so how am I actually
going to execute this now many many
things are probably strong 93 is
probably the easiest Bishop c3 is also
quite nice
[Music]
yeah this is I think is the easiest
especially if you consider it's a blitz
game like him if he takes his six attack
on c3 with the bishop and that wins the
game pretty straightforwardly as I'm
threatening Queen e3 with me to come and
the queen is attacked and okay if he
somehow covers I don't know how action
actually it's difficult to come to c3
rook to e3 I just go pawn to c4 and
that's it or maybe maybe I can also just
take it to them
c4 the screen a3 that's easy
no that's it basically don't see any way
for him to defend
Wow that's the huge text there's all
kinds of text and they were not the name
correspondence chess GM interesting okay
so but this is a game of chance to be
played
so what to do yes avoids the normal
looking move you can also just move the
knight I mean for for lazy chess okay
check on a3 is also not bad and I think
I do this this will probably win the
exchange fructify yeah that's the best
the best try
so just taking it I guess
you can check on g5 yes the easiest
thing on but thread queens ever trading
queens us a little bit boring him for
one to see three years also pretty nice
just a tech couldn't then keep this pawn
on the board like Bishop d7 rook c8
something like that
oopsy 8 Bishop a4 bishop and yeah what I
was trying to say not very successfully
is that I'm planning for Bishop inform
though the bishop on f4 and the knight
on f3 really are pretty miserable
how do we get the blue the a rook into
the game probably here and now a five a
four yeah that that reduces all the
pieces and he still does not have any
counter threats a five die supreme it is
a good news against basically anything
that that makes sense for watch but you
never know check
so it says something 1d form there
should be something rate this winner
check
and it's just not no fancy dropping or
whatever just played the moves
I'm also one minute down on a croc so
let's just take this we trade is a bit
lame but it wins very very simply it
stood like one minute and and why do
something fancy
check so what is the easiest here
probably just keep the pawn and improve
the position no you can be won on
something to trade down but this is
probably easiest just you cannot move
anything here yes he doesn't have any
positive thing that's what I'm trying to
say that he can try some can just get
the shine into the game
check white forfeits on time no yet that
trick really worked like a charm
yeah this line yeah I think is pretty
pretty okay for black kids it's getting
the game into yeah somewhat less less
usual territory which often is a good
idea against the London player who's
pretty much used to play the same kind
of setup every game so but he played
very intent of privately with long
castles and now yeah I can defy this is
giving me the game basically night
before was even stronger yeah it's
possible it's very possible that there's
some way of meeting but this was the the
simple thing to do just basically
keeping a big advantage without any
anything fancy there's much to check
check
yeah yeah if he does not play here with
this I have booked C form and then we
will give form with a continuing attack
Chanyeol and then what maybe you could
go quicker ways to do it but this was
simple and I think quite good if you are
having like one minute 30 or up on the
clock and you can go into it
selim winning ending it's not a bad idea
instead of trying to look for a maid
that probably isn't down okay guys
thanks for watching